in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week when you go to a
doctor he sometimes need to take your
pulse like this year I'm a GP myself and
I know that different kind of pulses
that can be slow and they can be fast
but if I go to a traditional Chinese
medicine doctor he knows about 28
different kinds of pulses
hi mrs. Inga thanks for inviting me into
your clinic you're a traditional doctor
for Chinese medicine right and where do
you find those pulses on both sides on
the right on the left hand side and
usually you find them if you do if you
apply your fingertips on each side and
you take actually three fingers on each
side and each position the left position
has like a superficial pass and then you
go a little bit deeper and then you have
a deep pass so there are three levels of
of pulses and that's what you do on both
sides interesting with the 28 to pass
the qualities you just talked about is
that you really find different past
qualities on each patient so some
patients ever very long pass so long
pass goes up to here for example or some
patients have a very deep pass so you
really have to press out in order to
find any quality of the pulse and then
you can also find like a very pulse we
call it it's a very tight quality of
pulses so what do you know after he took
the pulse after after the after taking
the pulse and the time usually in
combination
I can ask often questions to confirm
what I feel and then I can have an idea
where the problem lies of the patient so
the digests a problem or it has other
issues if you take a look at the
background or the medicinal Chinese
medicine there it's it's a complete
different system then like we use here
in Germany in the European version of
medicine and what are the differences
first of all the language is different
so usually when I want to talk about the
liver and living in a new system it's a
complete different idea to what I know
the liver for Chinese doctor is not the
organ we know which sits in the upper
right abdominal area thank you so
usually for us it's it's a functional
system
I never has a certain function so when
the liver doesn't work properly or the
flow of the liver doesn't work properly
patients might feel headache quite often
often in stressful situations or fears
of pressure in any civil case there are
different suitors to one organ where we
can define where the problem lies and do
you use those Western diagnostic systems
like Hydra sound or MRI scan we do
especially again this clinic we work in
a hospital here so we have possibilities
to actually ask our colleagues to check
certain patients that we're not sure
about and we would like to have the
support of listeners so it's a very
integrative method then yeah and and the
other way around does it work the other
way around that your colleagues from the
Western medicine refer patients to you
is it a Chinese doctor that works as
well especially for colleagues that
suffer from pain and a to have a quicker
result because they need to work again
so that's why we they come here and we
do
occupant said another techniques so so
pain is one thing and and what whether
they are the main diagnosis or analysis
you'd like to treat treat internal
medicine from digestive problems
sleeping disorders emotional disorders
is long there's a vast variety
possibilities for Chinese medicine
acupuncture treatment is perhaps the
most well known therapy in Chinese
medicine where do you find all those
points on the body it's easy to find on
each patient because each patient has
similar landmarks so like no matter what
I treat a child or a grown-up you cannot
just measure that by certain landmarks
bones muscle and then it's easy to find
those 365 points how many points you
treat at the same session and it depends
really from one to twenty different
points it really depends on the patient
the condition can you show us how you
treated us so what I use is them I use
them acupuncture needle which we use
only once very thin stainless steel
needles and then I use a guide tube
which makes it much easier for the
insertion for the patient because I keep
anxious pain-free and so you can just
that's all it's all so how do you feel
sir almost nothing so it's not that
painful and what happens in the body
after you insert the needle the
insertion of the needle just regulates
implement inflammation processes and
also the circulation that in Chinese
medicine we call it the flow of Chi in
of blood that we stimulate with the
acupuncture so Chi is the energy which
is flown through it
energy exactly so you try to to relieve
certain blockages of the body by using
the needles but there's even a Western
point of view when it comes to
acupuncture that there's some hormones
and neurotransmitters are secreted after
you you press with Annie Laurie exactly
there are lots of different scientific
researches but that has been done on
acupuncture and you can see that the
changes of hormones and even the blood
results um some of my patients bring new
blood results their changes throughout
the treatment as well it's quite
interesting okay acupuncture is one side
of Chinese medicine the other side is
herbal treatments and so what you do
with this kind of treatment
Herbert treatment is also important in
order to treat certain conditions so we
combine acupuncture herbal medicine and
herbal medicine they are usually we use
a combination of herbs usually between
five to twenty five thank if I would
have for example and osteoarthritis
degenerative bone disease and there is
no traditional Chinese doctor in my
vicinity so I have no chance to go to a
traditional Chinese doctor but I want to
use these herbs can I go into a pharmacy
and treat myself usually you need a
certain prescription which it's it's
very important to get a correct
diagnosis in order to get a good result
so what we usually do we have lots of
international patients that come to us
for a consultation and then if they live
away far away we usually they take to
the herbs for one or two months home and
then they come back to us I got a lot of
questions concerning traditional Chinese
medicine one from Qatar Halima al Kumari
wants to know if you can treat cancer
with means of TCM we have many patients
that come with cancer and they use
therapies like chemotherapy and what we
can do we can support the treatment by
giving vans herbs acupuncture to reduce
the side effects of chemotherapy
so you don't heal the cancer but you can
lessen the side-effects of the
traditional thanks so much for inviting
me into your clinic today thank you and
thank you so much for demonstrating the
architecture with us thank you